[Music]
today we return to the subject of racism
and parade mascots
uh it is not a subject that i would
choose to dwell on but this is a a show
that analyzes and discusses culture and
this is what our culture cares about so
to briefly review a few weeks ago
somebody in a sesame street costume at a
parade and sesame place in philadelphia
made the mistake of walking past a black
child without stopping to greet her
specifically of course mascots walk by
many children all the time without
greeting them for reasons that are
obvious but this one innocuous event was
caught on film conveniently clipped to
remove all context and nationwide
outrage ensued charges of racism were
made apologies were issued soon
afterwards another family filed a
class-action lawsuit on behalf of all
black families that have been victims of
similar mascot-related hate crimes
but the completely made-up problem of
racist mascots extends beyond sesame
street apparently the costumed rodents
at chuck e cheese are also racist
no telling if the actual rodents that
also frequent chuck e cheese are racist
as well but we can only take one problem
at a time this week another video went
viral of a black child being horribly
traumatized
by the minor disappointment of not
receiving a high five from a costumed
character
the mother of the victim tweeted the
shocking footage let's watch it
thank you thank you it's great to be
here with you to celebrate these amazing
birthday stars now for those of you who
don't know when you celebrate your
birthday at chuck e cheese's you are the
star of the show in fact
horrific
now she captioned this uh she captioned
this with this please retweet on july
30th at chuck e cheese in wayne new
jersey my two-year-old was racially
discriminated against as you can see he
gives all the white kids high fives and
purposely ignored my black baby when
confronted he ignored me as well the
manager angie velasquez made excuses for
him
ah yes that notorious white supremacist
angie velasquez of new jersey
that's a clan name if ever i've heard
one now she says that uh the manager
made excuses i can't imagine what those
excuses might be other than the fact
that all the kids who received high
fives were standing on a stage eye level
with the mascot the child who was
snubbed was standing three feet below
them given that your line of sight is
almost non-existent in those sweltering
death trap costumes the most logical
explanation is that the kids on the
stage were within his limited vision and
the child below the stage was not so
that's a logical explanation but it's
not a lucrative explanation
if you're looking to cash in as this
mother clearly is then the only
explanation you'll possibly entertain is
that the person in the mouse costume who
you don't know and who may be black
themselves for all you know is racist
not only that but for whatever reason
the costumed character gig attracts
racist there is a conspiracy among
mascots nationwide to traumatize black
children
this is what you allege when your demand
for racism far far outstrips the supply
now for the record chuck e cheese was of
course prepared to fold at a moment's
notice they didn't put up any fight at
all i mean none
chuck e cheese corporate released a
statement expressing that they were
deeply saddened by this event quote as
home to millions of families and kids
every year that celebrates the big and
small milestones including fun
our goal is to create an inclusive
experience for children and parents of
all ages races ethnicities religious
backgrounds and learning differences
our mission is to provide a fun and safe
place where a kid can be a kid and all
cast members are trained to ensure that
we live up to this promise
now you notice how on the left
where they pretend to champion the poor
and the working class they have no
problem at all with giant corporations
making scapegoats out of their minimum
wage employees throwing them throwing
them to the wolves
and branding them with the letter r for
racist
you know they have no problem with that
because because of course these people
don't give the slightest damn about the
working class or the poor or anybody
else
in fact the more powerless somebody is
the better because the easier it is to
get them to dance to your tune the
leftist outrage mob thrives on
manipulation and intimidation it is
their fetish
they feel orgasmic delight at the sight
of some poor sap bowing before them this
was made all the more apparent yesterday
when another video went viral
this one from a parade at disney world
but the mascot these are toy story
characters this time around um they
didn't make the same mistake so in this
video woody
spots a black girl in the crowd
and frantically waves for the other toy
story character to come over so that she
can greet the child let's let's watch
that happen
talking he keep calling me crying
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so i actually i don't know if that
music was actually playing at the parade
for kids i wouldn't be surprised if it
was i don't think it was i think that
was just put in in post
um so you see there the person in the
cowgirl costume i don't know what what's
the name of that character i don't know
um
what was it say it again
jessie okay
jessie and the cowgirl there um almost
walked by the black child without
noticing her which would have been
as we've seen a national tragedy and a
catastroph catastrophe of historic
proportions fortunately though through
woody's diligent efforts she noticed at
the last second and sprinted over to
give the young black girl the biggest
and most specialist greeting out of all
the other kids at the parade
never mind that she didn't hug the other
black kids right next to that girl
i guess she's going to get a pass in
this case until the parents of those
kids decide to sue for a hundred million
dollars of course
now the media has been um reporting on
that little video there like it's a
heartwarming sort of human interest
story
but it's actually quite sad and pathetic
and terrifying
the minimum wage lackey in the costume
knows that they'll be smeared nationally
as a racist probably fired
and may be sued if they don't specially
acknowledge every black child or at
least every black child with a litigious
parent holding a camera
the hug was a hug given by someone who
knows that they're going to be
arbitrarily attacked libeled and
destroyed if they commit an entirely
innocuous and innocent oversight
this is somebody frantically trying to
avoid a fate
that shouldn't be anywhere within the
ballpark of possibilities in the first
place there should be zero risk that a
kid in a costume at a parade will end up
in the headlines for accidentally
walking past a black child in the crowd
there should be no risk of that
this is now a real risk in our depraved
idiot-infested culture
now the situation is not sustainable i
mean ultimately
and this will happen within the next few
months probably if not weeks companies
like disney and sesame street and chugga
cheese will instate policies forbidding
mascots from greeting anybody at all
allowing them to do greetings is now a
liability because if any video surfaces
of any mascot failing to greet any black
child even if that same mascot greeted
50 black children before it becomes a pr
scandal and probably a lawsuit
companies will judge it simply not worth
the risk and they're going to do away
with what was once totally normal and
seemingly risk-free
the outrage mob destroys then yet
another small little thing that once
brought joy to children but now must be
taken away because the parasites got a
hold of it
and the most important thing we can
learn from this and take note of
is again
just how much joy
these leeches take in all of this
you know the the their uh the leftist
mob they were passing around that video
for the disney world video yesterday
laughing hysterically about it they
think it's the greatest thing in the
world
the very people who pretended to be
upset at sesame street and chuck e
cheese are laughing
because they can see that their charade
has its desired effects
because they love nothing in this world
more than seeing people jump through the
hoops that they have set up
and that's all the more reason
to never give these frauds what they
want defy them at every opportunity
laugh in their faces
never apologize
before they have a chance to say it to
you
you must always say to them
you are cancelled
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated